[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour se mettre de bonne humeur le matin
à la rigueur un petit peu de temps en
temps ça fait du bien
voilà
c'est pas le dimanche matin mais
c'est l'appel à la prière
d'ailleurs une fois que j'y pense allez
pouvoir dire la messe
[Musique]
abba
tout à fait
et
[Musique]
ce
dans
bienne
m
[Musique]
l'autre ne nous appartient pas on en est
pas le propriétaire on n'a pas à lui
dire toi tu es comme ci ou comme ça ben
non
et partout finalement dans le monde eh
ben on aurait tendance à dire toi tu
m'appartiens je te domine à travers
l'argent je te domine à travers la
manipulation psychologique ou autre
vous ferez cela en mémoire de moi
la jeune fille au revoir bon dimanche
aussi bon dimanche
bon dimanche frédéric je vais voir la
mama ba oui c'est repos et plus faut que
je m'occupe à plein
[Musique]
nous
e
[Musique]
oco mémoire
ah bah
ça s'est bien passé ta mère se bat pas
impeccable
pas tant que ça ce matin ils étaient
frileux enfin ils sont pas venus
mais là vraiment oui bon qu'un tiers
cauchemar ils
ont nommé li devait pas trop mal quand
van ils sont pas partis dans ce but ils
ont accès aux données de santé à nous
arrivé sur la levée de la loire
l'harmonie votre sacyr l'église de saint
cyr mbi j'ai quelque chose d'important
dire
oui et moi je m'attendais à ce qu'il me
dise que d'une fille
et puis
je dis bon et puis il me dit non je
voudrais rentrer un séminaire a alors la
trempe latin prix soucoupes volantes
dilf attendait tout sauf à ça
mais bon bah gym dit tout de suite agi
non pas tout de suite
parce que faut que tu fini ses études
parce qu'on sait pas si tu pourras aller
jusqu'au bout parce que je savais que
c'est au mois six ans
[Musique]
ça ce sont des photos qui ont été prises
dans le jardin au 1073
au prat bah oui au printemps donc ça
devait à dimanche en menant de la messe
qui s'était bien habillé
ils savaient ce qu'ils voulaient très
bien et
c'était comme ça c'était pas autrement
un peu coléreux parce que ils sont mais
ils vendent vite mais testant aussi vite
ça 179 c'est quand je faisais un combat
de judo
et puis ça sur un bassin c'est le jour
de sa première communion là c'était
leclerc qui faisait sa profession de foi
et de noix qui avait fait sa première
communion
[Musique]
ça représente quoi d'avoir un fils
prêtre
dans une grotte jours c'est une grande
joie ça
je crois que c'est la plus grande joie
de ma vie
[Musique]
e
où
[Musique]
on va les voir
alors tu vois le 19 juin il fallait
une grande tornade est arrivée
était comme une scène de guerre il y
avait de la pierre des pierres partout
du bois les gens qui commençaient à
ramasser comme si ça d'exploser
à c'était monstrueux
est-ce qu'on peut passer la wii on va
essayer de se faufiler
une église c'est aussi là c'est l'âme
des paroissiens
quand il s'est encore ils s'envolent
quelques quelque chose d'eux s'envole
aussi avec comme s'il y avait une
certaine petite mort à vivre et même
s'ils mettent pas les pieds l'église au
dimanche qu'importe ses valises
ses anciennes grilles de communion de
banques communion et
et
là ça les a complètement plié
face à fish un coup de plus oui c'est
vrai que dans une église où on a d'une
part les problèmes sur la pédophilie et
puis aussi la raréfaction des prêtres en
plus bon
ça qui vient en plus là-dessus bas on se
dit bon on est toujours debout encore et
c'est peut-être ça aussi ce qui
caractérise un chrétien c'est que malgré
les épreuves il est toujours debout
toujours
attention
après il y aura du grand moulin genève
je te donne tu es chaud son
bonjour tester ça va bien
[Musique]
beaucoup c'est parti mon kiki
je veux
[Musique]
c'est très important de pouvoir faire
ses exercices d'abord je dois perdre du
poids
cette fois
c'est pas rien
pour cette petite mère elle est heureuse
que je sois très bien tes bras derrière
mamadou ibra
même pour le ministère
ça
ça donne un acquis du caractère quoi
et puis ça apporte aussi une grande
maîtrise de soi
t'as pas trop chaud que ça va
bien
nous appelons tous les gens
[Musique]
attention quand
sachant que la loi
oui
sagna
on est dans le temps ordinaire de
l'église et dans ce temps ordinaire le
but du jeu c'est de pouvoir ressembler
davantage à la personne même de jésus au
moins dans sa façon de faire et des mets
dans le coeur bat ça veut dire que
on est content mais surtout s'il battait
plus
bas plus que malheureusement
on serait mort ben oui voilà donc
finalement le bonheur c'est bien la vie
mais par contre il faut trouver des
solutions pour vous puissiez quand même
avoir de quoi manger tous les jours quoi
vous inquiétez pas c'est pas le mal qui
est contre vous c'est que bass ed a
essayé de constance de la vie c'est ça à
très bientôt et bon courage en attendant
oui d'accord à bientôt
j'avais reçu un appel du maire déjà oui
et chapelles à la chapelle sur loire il
ya une dame qui n'a plus le moindre
sourire à manger mais j'ai pas bien
manger pour deux jours
et je vais voir aussi avec over sens
mais il faut reconnaître que ça m'énerve
de voir qu'un autre époque on ne peut
peut arriver
est ce que te montre heureux
je me souviens d'une petite fille comme
ça j'avais baptisé six mois plus tôt six
mois après josé son enterrement et puis
de voir le père
porté le cercueil blanc tout seul enfin
ajouté
j'en voulais à dieu qu'enfin même lui
fin ils pouvaient rien pourtant mai
on se dit mais enfin il aurait pu faire
quelque chose
[Musique]
le seul point de mire mois pour
l'instant que je vois c'est cette
espérance que toujours le christ mettra
dans son église je savais qu'il y avait
des prédateurs dans l'église et ce qui
était pour moi un fait inconcevable
vraiment
mais ce qui m'a fait le plus mal c'est
qu'il y ait eu du silence dans la
hiérarchie l'église
on découvre finalement qu'on n'est pas
tous coupables ça c'est vrai mais par
contre on est tous responsables
et ça il faut bien en prendre conscience
on n'est pas là pour imposer quoi que ce
soit on est là pour essayer donner un
sens à la vie et ses sens sont là nous
même reçu et on essaye de leur donner
[Musique]